my name is Ellie Miranda my colleague
Clement Bella been a longtime
small talk implementer I was here in
2003 giving a presentation in the same
course on the system that we're
describing now which at the time was an
architecture in my head something that I
that I hoped to implement and in fact
it's been these 13 years that it's taken
for me to find collaborators in space to
actually complete the project and get to
a stage where I can deliver on the
vision that I had then so you might
think that those 13 years were long
enough in which a project might become
completely irrelevant and and be
discarded but it has not been the case
so you know follow your dream and never
give up and you may get to to realize it
we are in the business of making it
efficient to run dynamic languages
dynamic languages all the rage right now
you almost certainly use JavaScript in
your daily work as a student and adding
behavior to to webpages etc this is an
example in small talk and it simply sums
the elements of a collection and so it's
an abstract method that sits at the top
of a collection hierarchy and it's
inherited by a lot of different concrete
collection classes and the first thing
you see is that there's no types and we
initialize a variable with the with the
integer zero and we don't bother to
declare some or anything like that we
can just assign it and the second thing
you see these these square brackets
around the colon element sum becomes
equal to sum plus element close bracket
is a closure so we create a code closure
and we provide that as an argument to an
iterator message do and we ask the
receiver to apply that closure to all of
its elements
and each of the many subclasses of the
collection abstract class may indeed
implement do in its own particular way
depending on its its interior
representation it might be a hash table
with with keyed keys that are key value
pairs and we need to iterate over that
hash table it might be a flat array
where we can use integer indexes it
might be a computed interval from from
one start value to another and we don't
know when the do is written what do will
will be executed so what you can see
here is a very very concise code but
very generic code and code that's been
factored into lots of small methods so
one of the problems that dynamic
languages opposed to the implementer is
that we have very little scope for
optimization another more important is
that we've got lots and lots of calls
even in doing something simple like
iterating over an array where in in a
standard procedural language the
compiler would be able to reduce
everything to talk to machine
instructions here there's no scope to to
find the very limited scope to find
machine instructions in fact there's a
there's a lot of abstraction here but
one of our lovely convenience is that we
have in dynamic languages is that you
know sitting there looking at this I
could add another optimization I could
add another implementation of some in a
subclass and so here's some in a
subclass which assumes that it's
instances are indexable with the integer
indices from from one to self.size we
don't know how self.size is implemented
but we're assuming that we've got a to
do method which takes the integers and
which will sum by using an indexing
operator at again a dynamically bound
send which is going to find the element
associated with with with
and it's really nice that I could just
sit there and and and add that but
that's a real problem for the for the
execution system the execution system is
is dealing with dynamically bound sends
or all the way through it's it's its
execution so how is it so ok how is it
that these things are typically executed
we typically have a heap which is which
is full of objects some of which is code
and we have some components like a
memory manager and an execution engine
which might be an interpreter and some
primitive operations and the the
interpreters job is to interpret that
dynamic code and of course the
experience is that that the system is is
is too slow and that what we need to do
is to add some form of compilation if we
add ahead of time copulation we're going
to lose all of our dynamic advantages so
we need a just-in-time compiler that
will compile the code on demand because
that's a really nice way of dealing with
the ability to add code to the system
and modify code to the system so then we
can think of the VM architecture as a
heap of objects some zone in which the
the JIT produces code it might be
interspersed in the heap but in the
systems that I've been working with it's
always in its own own area and the
execution engine is now hybrid one that
it can interpret and it can it can
compile one of the the issues you have
in in jetting is if you think about a
method which is interpreted only once
let's say some some method that was
interpreted at startup it's much more
expensive to to JIT which is essentially
an interpretation over the code with the
side-effects that you produce the
machine code concatenate the machine
code for the for the operations
concerned and so you might actually
benefit from being able to avoid
cheating until you might execute a
method for a for a sec
time so there are actually advantages to
having this this mixed context so that's
the the architecture of the small talk--
virtual machines that I'm going to be
discussing today and similar to a number
of other executions so going back to
that example of the indexing via at in
our second some call how could it be
that we can improve performance avoiding
the cost of every time we send a message
figuring out what code is to be executed
well in the in the 80s Peter Deutsch
with the small virtual machine done at
Xerox PARC invented the inline caching
technique so imagine that my method is
is compiled to a byte coded language and
there are there are byte codes which
represent things like pushing the
receiver pushing an instance variable
etc and might go from making a
particular send so I'm considering here
is the the compilation of the of the
send instruction for the at message that
we send to whatever self is and the JIT
compiler generates a two instruction
sequence for this and it loads a
register here I've got our CX which I'm
using as a mnemonic for class it loads a
register with the the address
effectively of the of the symbol that
names the the the a procedure call and
then it calls some runtime routine in
the VM and if that code was ever to be
executed then what that runtime routine
would do would be using the that some
other register which has the self in it
that we haven't shown how the compilers
reference self but it'll look up the the
message at in whatever the class of self
is and in this case I'm imagining that
it's an array and
we'll find some buy coded method and
associated with a bike coded method it
may find some machine code method and if
there's no machine code method it'll
actually have to create one so what it
can do is is is is having its hand the
machine code form for the array at
method which would actually index the
the array and to optimize sending it's
going to modify the original two
instruction sequence so now instead of
loading the register with the name of
the procedure we load the register with
with the class of the object which
received the message in this case it's
in an array so we have is is a load of
the class array into this this register
and we're going to call an entry point
in the machine code and and and when we
do this on first execution the compiler
will jump to the body of the of the
method and execution will continue but
the second time around what will happen
is that will execute these instructions
so now our CX will will have any array
and we'll go to the entry point of the
array method and what that will do is
given that that self is is in a
dedicated register it will find out the
class of self which is the class of self
at this send not the send at the time
when we compiled and it simply compares
the two and if the two are the same then
execution continues so now we've reduced
some kind of hash look up where we're
associating sums and class and some
selector with that with a method with a
very simple fetch the class of an object
and and compare it against the constant
and and continue so this is a lot
quicker and this was the technique that
the Peter Deutsch developed in the 80s
that gave us the first efficient
Smalltalk machines on commodity hardware
was on sixty eight thousand processors
so then the question comes well okay
what happens if I add some polymorphism
into the system so here what I've got is
I've got the array one two three that's
a hash parentheses one two three close
parentheses literal notation Smalltalk
literal notation
for an array which has three elements in
it but the second one one two three is
effectively equivalent but it's quite
different it's an interval so it has a
start and a stop and a step right and so
it implements at in a completely
different way it implements app by doing
some arithmetic right it multiplies the
step by the the index and adds it to the
start so if I was to evaluate that in in
my collection it turns out that in my in
my library on the on the first slide
turns out that these are both sequence
elections so they would both inherit
this second method right and when we
came to execute that at here this send
comparison that we've generated here
would fail so what happens when it fails
what we do then is have the failure path
in the method call into the runtime and
now locate the new class and create a
little table a little dispatch table in
machine code on the fly to invoke the
original method and invoke the new
method and we call that a polymorphic
inline cache the first thing is called
an inline cache it caches one message
lookup and what we're going to do is
produce some simple lookup table that
will deal with some degree of
polymorphism and typically it's
convenient right and in the in in the
JIT to decide how big this table is and
you initially fill it in with two at two
elements and you allow it to grow to
some number for example like six and
then if you get to two megamorph extends
you have to use another strategy but
we're not going to discuss those
strategies today I just wanted to give
you this example so when we execute this
in the context of the the interval the
one two three some we're gonna get a
failure and we're going to call this
this sorry
once we've rebound we're going to call
this pick and this pick just does a
series of comparisons so the first entry
compares the the current class against
array and jumps to the no check entry
point which will execute the code and
the second case checks for interval and
and and so on and this this is stretchy
so it might be able to expand to some
number of cases
so that's great and and it turns out
that if you look at small talk vm's
which don't have polymorphic inline
caches they spend a large percentage of
their execute time for example like 50%
of entire execution rebinding these
entries as as the number of classes
changes it turns out that sort of 90% of
the sends in a program have only one
class but this remaining 10% are
extremely expensive to deal with because
they're failing all or all of the time
and when you when you replace with this
this nice table
technique you oops you get rid of that
overhead and get a substantial speed-up
well okay so now we're in the 90s and
the team itself and indeed at Stanford
under Dave Unger were dealing with a
language which was even more difficult
to optimize the small talk self which is
prototype based and because it's
prototype based there's even more
polymorphism because individual objects
have their own methods instead of object
being members of classes and they were
struggling to produce an efficient
execution engine using conventional
compiler technology and type inference
and were failing and so they they went
this route and added pix as a way of
dealing with the higher degree of
polymorphism but then they realized this
collects type information so associated
with every send that is been executed in
the program we have either a monomorphic
cache which says for this send location
we only ever had one type of receiver or
for the other mega morphic a polymorphic
sends we know the set of classes that
we've seen so far and that's information
which is perfect for an optimizing
compiler to use the the only problem
about it is that it is speculative it
tells you what happened in the past it
doesn't help tell you what what happened
in the future it will will discuss that
soon so the the thing that we need to do
is to use that information for an
optimizing compiler
but if we really nearly optimized our
code our dynamic performance is going to
suffer because we're going to spend all
of this time optimizing code
aggressively so what we need to do is
find some way of only optimizing when
appropriate and most most programs
observe this pattern of 90% of the time
is in 10% of the code or 95% of the time
is in 5% of the code so if we decorate
our machine code produced by our first
level chip with counters and we can make
those counters affordable what we can do
is allow those counters to identify the
hotspots as they were called in the the
first Java VM the hotspots in the
program that would profit from
optimization so we modify our baseline
JIT to put in counters now in our system
we and in a number of Java systems we
count conditional branches you could
count every message send every method
activation well that's that's rather
expensive it turns out that in in
typical small talk programs conditional
branch these are about six times less
frequent so counting conditional
branches is a much better cheaper
technique of finding hotspots but it
also gives a nice ability to but we
haven't exploited that ability yet but
we'd like to of having the the counter
being able to tell you how many times
you've encountered the conditional
branch and how many times you took the
conditional branch so you can get basic
block counts and and and know what is
the the common path so then what what
happens in in these these VMs and I
should say that hotspot was the first
commercially available VM that used this
technique was available in 1999 and has
evolved successively since then and
that's the the Sun hot spot now the
Oracle hot spot VM for for Java but you
see similar techniques in the Chrome
JavaScript VM which is called v8 in the
WebKit which is the apple VM for Chrome
and in a number of other dynamic
languages so what happens is that when a
counter trips there's there's some kind
of pause and we invoke an optimizer and
in this diagram I'm writing the optimize
as a black box
because optimizes is it is typically in
the VM it's actually in the VM with with
with the rest of the runtime so it's
part of that that lower level and it's
implemented in C++ alright and I can't
see it from the from the top and then
what the optimizer does is generate some
machine code in fact what it does is
analyze the stack and and try and an
inline a whole series of the the byte
coded methods and I've drawn my bike
coding methods on the on the Left inline
those those by coding methods to produce
some much bigger machine code method
which which covers essentially a large
portion of the of the core graph and by
inlining a large portion of the core
graph we now have much more opportunity
to to optimize using conventional
techniques and of course inlining has
has avoided all of those those call
overheads but the problem is that the
code is still dynamic and we could still
introduce new types into the program so
what we do is is is put guards in the
machine code at the start of each basic
block which makes assumptions as to the
types that it's in inline and those
those guards must must be passed must
verify that the classes are as expected
and if those guards fail then we have to
do something else and we have to do this
hairy thing of D optimizing the
optimized code so that the stack is now
reverted to its its unoptimized case and
let the system run again and then when
the counters trip again we will re
optimize in the presence of the new type
information so there's this kind of big
cycle
okay so um that's great
but I don't like C++ I've never enjoyed
using it and I'm a small talker and
small talk is kind of different
you saw the language doesn't even have
curly brackets it's got square brackets
like JavaScript but how is it different
well the real difference is that small
talk is self representing so methods and
classes are first-class objects like any
other like like those arrays etc and
there's there's code in the system which
define the behavior of classes and code
in the system which defines the behavior
of methods and how to create them etc
and so the implication of this is really
nice the compiler the source code
compiler that takes a small talk source
code produces byte coded methods and it
is a small talk program and you can if
you want modify the compiler while
you're working on your project you might
want to insert some some some strange
code to monitor the use of your instance
variables or whatever you might want to
do that you can you can do that so yeah
that's right but small talk thank takes
things to not to extremes but to a point
of consistency so that we have a minimal
number of concepts to consider and one
of the things that it does is represent
activation records as objects to now an
activation record was an activation
record an activation record is that
which records the state of a method
activation or procedure activation so
it's either where I am I in the current
method what's my PC what are the values
of my my arguments and my local
variables and and where do I have to
return if I have to return a result
so having activation records as objects
has a number of implications and one of
them is that the the debugger is simply
an interpreter over activation records
because when the program is is is in any
any any state where an error has
happened and I've caught the error I can
have a look at the at the stack and one
of the one of the errors that I can have
is simply an error that that Holtz the
system that boots me into a debugger
which in it is written in small talk and
then in that debugger I can step through
the the code and so a traditional
debugger like like a c-level debugger
which displays stack frames which are on
a machine stack is replaced by an
inspector for a linked list of
activation records and and that's my
model so it's very nice because I can do
things like implement exception search
which needs to search activation records
to find handler just like just like I do
any other small to a code so exception
search is not down in the VM it's it's
something that I can program and
something that I can alter it also means
that if I want to do something like
implement partial continuations which
have been used in many applications but
as nice ways of dealing with with with
web servers where you know the back
button means that suddenly I've got you
know where was I in this web page and
where am I in this web page it would be
really nice to to be able to go forward
etc it'd be really nice to deal with
that by being able to take copies of the
stack and remember what state I was when
the user hit the back button and
activation records as objects makes it
trivial to implement that kind of
control structure so it might seem
exotic but it actually has very
practical applications no ok so there's
there's a severe performance overhead
and the early Smalltalk VM suffered from
this this problem of having to allocate
an activation record every time we send
a method and one of the things is that
if we've got activation records which
are distinct objects then the arguments
that were marshalling as we as we make a
send in one activation have to be copied
to the activation record which executes
the method whereas in stack frames the
outgoing arguments become the incoming
arguments on the stack and everything's
overlap
but in implementing that inline cash
Peter Deutz had to solve the problem of
mapping this execution model to real
machine instructions and so he also
solved the problem of mapping ax
activation record objects to stack
frames so in fact what happens in a real
vm is that we can create conventional
stack frames and when the programmer
asks for an activation record for the
current activation we give it an object
which is kind of a proxy to the stack
frame and that's created on demand so we
don't have the overhead that you might
the you might think but we still have
the freedom in the language even though
in the VM we're not actually creating
context a lot that when we want we have
a way of accessing our current execution
state from within the system as a
first-class object so the question
becomes okay given what we've got
methods and our you know a compiler and
everything else and activation records
could we actually implement speculative
inlining above the vm entirely in small
talk and have this really complicated
piece of optimization technology be
something that you could interactively
develop while you were interacting with
your your program and your test cases
and be written in a garbage collected
high-level language and the answer is
yes so now the model of our our system
is that yeah on the Left we have by
coded methods which are compiled by the
baseline JIT into machine code with with
counters and now when those counters
trip I arranged that a message is sent
back into the small talk system just
like an exception arising from from that
from the runtime and now my optimizer is
a small talk program so it's a white box
and what that optimizer does is output a
byte coded method which represents the
inlining of many many simple by coded
methods
but since we want to get the same
performance as an aggressive optimizing
compiler that is that is targeting
machine instructions we don't want to
use the abstract bytecode that only
encodes for abstract operations like
like the Act which is which is not bound
if you look at the how app is actually
implemented once you get to an array
then there's a primitive operation in
the VM which is going to examine the the
object and examine the argument and make
sure that everything's valid and
actually yield the the object so that's
that that primitive
is is Harry the receiver might be a
immediate object might be a tagged
pointer or it might be an object and so
it has to ask that question and then it
might be an array of bytes owner array
of characters it might be an array of
object several different kinds of arrays
and so we have to dispatch on the kind
of array to find out what kind of
operation is and when we find out what
how the object is represented only then
can we do the bounds check because then
we know how big the elements are and and
and then we have to index so you might
see as many as 80 or 100 machine
instructions in the implementation of
the app primitive and and that's really
no good what we want to do in optimized
code is generate the one instruction or
the two instructions that just fetch a
given field of an object so the way that
we do that by maintaining our
architecture is that we extend our byte
code set with one byte code that can
encode for unsafe operations so this is
a byte code which is not legal for the
normal compiler to generate it's only
legal for the optimising compiler to
generate once it's proved then in this
particular context is safe to use this
particular instruction and so these byte
codes which I've done in red code for
unsafe operations like okay you're
indexing something that looks like an
array and you can be sure that the index
is a small integer that's in range and
so the JIT is free to generate just the
the two instructions and go ahead and
then this method is installed in some
method dictionary and the
next time it's it's sent the jet is
going to baseline JIT which has now been
extended in a very simple way with
support for generating these
instructions is going to generate the
equivalent method and in exactly the
same way if the execution of the
speculatively inline code fails one of
its guards and we find out that there's
more polymorphism we're going to fail
but this time our D optimizer is again a
white box and it can manipulate these
first-class activation records to
convert the one inlined optimized
activation record into the the set of
unoptimized things and allow the system
to continue but the advantage now is
that all of that machinery that was
executed in a low-level non
garbage-collected language in a
traditional vm is now available to us in
in a very very powerful concise dynamic
language so at this point I hand over to
Clem oh okay so I'm going to take the
example of how a specific method is
optimized I choose to pick this method I
am I hope you will be able to understand
it so this method is called display it
takes an argument which is list of doing
a notice already expand what message to
does it's an iterative method that it is
about the collection and at each
iteration of all the collection the
message send disciplined unseen is sent
to the receiver self with the argument
drink so the traditional way this method
will be executed and conventional of the
tones in your machine is as flow so the
first time the loop body is greeted the
mr. send discipline screen the paper
machine needs to fetch which method is
actually called for the specific
stricter and then can then can cache it
in the global method cash and can
interpret the byte code of the metal
during the next shoe addiction it will
keep interpreting but will not need to
fetch to do the root to perform the
lookup because to the
I look up cause it is already in the
cache then horribly on the seventh
execution in our photo machine it's
usually the saloon of gothic fiction the
best manjit compiler which night machine
code for the display for the body
so genetic machine cut takes a bit of
time but the ejection time of the
generation method will be smaller the
machine cut is ducati with inline caches
as explained a lot and in our case with
counters the next thousand execution the
machine cut 19 bazoombas language in
Copiah we will be executed then sir then
after a thousand execution we need to
adaptively recompile limited best and
types who have met and best undo
controls to generate much more efficient
can't good so this at this step the
completion time will be greater than the
westerns it but the cardinality will be
much faster and so basically there is a
trade-off between completion time and
execution time and depending on the
virtual machine this is done in two or
three or four step forward get so in our
example we will execute the method
display with over 30,000 rings so as
india to explain the what will happen is
that at some point the machine cut
version of the method which is generated
with candles and conditional punches
will detect that this method is not
reused so we added the printers and
punches because we believe that Belgian
waffle our heat indices in Easter less
overhead compared to automated counter
so the thing is due to our design the
the method display cannot detect hot
spot because it does not have any one
but two method do as the to do method
which is similar to far in
falou pink emotional language and it has
a bunch to escape the loop so these
methods can actually detect a hot spot
under a skipping munch so if we execute
that over 30,000 time the why don't we
why don't we say that so um what happens
with the small talk compiler to improve
performance of a small series of
selectors is that the bytecode compiler
translates if-then-else while true to do
and an or into into into branch branch
code so some message and and and we made
the mistake of not realizing that it's
implicit but a small set of the of the
control messages are actually compiled
down to branch byte codes and and so the
way to read want to self size to do is
kind of you know index becomes equal to
1 index less than or and limit becomes
equal to self size index less than or
equal to limit while truth and the
compiler is is generating a conditional
branch so the problem is that once the
hotspot is detected
what can we optimize in that method
because we have the same problem as me
as we thought there is very little that
we can optimize because we still have
all the attackers all the message sense
like self size like at like the
evaluation of the cruiser so one thing
that cause clearly a lot in our one time
is the fashion of crew zero on the
evolution of cruiser
so here the message value will actually
ever a to develop treasure and in the
automated display we were catching a
pleasure so when the hotspot is detected
we have to account state of the stack so
the bottom stack frame is Steph removed
emitted do and the from juice above is a
stifling for display so the thing that
the optimizer can do is look ahead in
the stack to find the best method to
optimize and it happens that because of
the block evaluation and the out of
frame is creating the block and this
frame is evaluating the block so if we
are able to
in line the bottom fan into the outer
FEM we will be able to remove the blood
fashion on the block of high evolution
so for this purpose the optimizer will
found out that the best method to
optimize is one method ahead another
column is like display is probably used
in a user application so it could be
very specific with probably specific
types and things like that
typically list of drinks will always be
an away the do method can be shared
between multiple collection and it's
courage to difficult to optimize the do
meter if it's at the top of the
hierarchy because it will be used by so
many so many part of the system that
there is a high chance that there will
be polymorphic sense like inside the
method so what we do is that we want to
speculatively in nine donation due to
replace the do send by actual metal so
the way we do that is that we use type
feedback so as adult mention with the
inline caches we can know for each sin
site the types we have already met for
the receiver so in our case the the
optimizing opera can know that for the
fifty thousand previous execution due
west and only on an array in that
specific sin site the second concept to
introduce is guards
so as the optimization is speculative we
need to be able to guarantee that this
figuration is always correct so if in
the future the this method will be
called not with an array but with an
order of correction of a dictionary
we need to dynamically optimize the code
to restore the unoptimized state and
execute the correct version of the code
yeah
so as the optimist method that we will
generate as inline multiple method if
the guard fail will be we will need to
document a cram into multiple step runs
so the way it works is that first we are
the guard that ensures that the argument
list of drinks
correctly to class all right and so I
hide this the Smalltalk Revell a pseudo
code so people can understand but this
cannot actually be expressed as well to
cleverly it can be expressed only at
beta code and machine code lover and
then we have in line the first method do
then we realize that we are immediately
creating a closure and even reaching the
crucial objects afterwards we cannot
remove the crucial question an
evaluation scenario would want optimizes
the access to the I so either got
explain I'm not going to be through
everything again
but the accessing to an hour in smoke is
a very expensive person we need to check
if the index is an integral if it's in
bones which is the actual type of the
object so as we know right now that list
of tank as the class RI we know that
another olds actually object-oriented
Ponte inside it's not a biter I for
example we know the and because of the
loop which iterates between one on the
size of the eye the optimizing compiler
can know that the index is always in
boons
so we are able to use an unsafe
operation that Jackie access to the
speech field field of Java okay so the
overall optimize our architecture works
as follow
so it's implemented fully in small talk
it takes as input a stack which is a
refight stack in the Smalltalk language
well hotspot has been detected and it
takes as input the branch and type
information that has been gathered from
the inline caches and the counters from
the coffee machine what the optimizer
does is to generate an optimized code
admitted but also dependents information
so this is because for example when you
nine Demeter do it's possible that the
small tube for now we would like to
redefine that method and I will change
this be
and when this method will be redefined
we need to discard all the optimized
method that we have in ninth that method
to recover stable state and less swing
generated by using compiler is a dope
transition metadata which is used to be
able to recover the optimistic pond of
domestic hand and optimized egg hunts
so the optimizer works as d combining
the byte code admitted into a single
static assignment control flow graph
which is a classical Internet
representation for compilers then it
does some optimization passes and it
generates bike byte code which is
different from Westborough so the
compiler works as a scanner which needs
to analyze things like jumps like
anticipator well the Beck Jones will
target and things like that then it
builds a control flow graph it does mean
are things like and canonical using a
loop to expect them in a specific state
and more importantly it asked vector
machine to provide the type annotation
that were available in the Yankees and
the decompile will annotate every year
of your childhood
we've to type in annotation so it cannot
reuse all the type information for
ending and then we do always certain
formations adding fine add something
like that so the current architecture in
the contract structure we use a menu
like three optimization so the first one
is speculative in 90s which is high
before so we will add a guard to ensure
that the speculation is always correct
and we will inline the method on the
crucial evolution then we try to do some
100 musician so as shown we we do things
like removing bounced check for the add
method we also do we also remove
overflow checks so in a similar way to
at the press operation
small talk will automatically can cast a
small small representation of integrals
to representation of large integrals and
if the optimizer can figure out that the
another flow never happens it does not
need to do the overflow check and lastly
and this is very important for our
language like small talk we fold the
constants so what's happening is that we
have many very shopped methods that just
answer the distance our constants like
an object's check here if it has a
specific type or something so lastly and
this is the I think the untraditional
part we need to convert back to a
presentation to bytecode so this is a
bit strange we the first thing we do is
to convert the SSF presentation to a
stack-based representation so we need to
make back which value will be actually
at my variable and which value will be
spilt on stack then in a similar way we
will allocate hajjaj styles we map all
the temporaries to specific slot so for
example if we have inline of multiple
methods it's possible that the same
temporary a multiple Tom Perez will
shout the Senate on power I struts in
which my time unless Lee we uncut the
optimized metal into white pad set so
another interesting part is about the
optimization so a typical problem that
we exist in a super special machine is
that you need at the same time to map
from the Machine state so things like
which values in a body style which value
is boxed onion box and also we get at
the same time which per second for one
second in our case we have already the
baseline JIT compiler that provide a
brief introduction of the stack frame at
the language in the language and the
best Imperial regime AppStore gist of
state to stack states it's already boxed
super exit one box and so the the way to
do Chima is our work it has an optimized
stack frame
that looks like it's a it's a method
that has been executed by the bytecode
interpreter everything is in stack and
everything is is object from with the
dopes mission metadata it's able to he
had multiple stacks come from one stack
farm and it's also able to happens to
occur objects data like for example
catching a blood pressure right if you
if you look at the example the original
example if we were to get some pores
halfway through there's a a closure that
the optimizing compiler completely
eliminated and yet when we
deoptimization we have to imagine what
would it be like and and create the
object so that so that the state is is
exactly the same so the optimizing
compiler is actually able to lead object
creations and the D optimization process
quite complicated has to construct an
exact copy of the state as it had been
had the optimization never never
occurred yeah so different days before
so the problem is that it will took we
can load new code while the program is
running we can edit the matter - well
documenting and if the method egt is
already in line in an optimized method
that optimize method needs to be
discarded so we need to have a very
strict management of the dependency for
each optimized method to see if it needs
to be discarded when new collision
started so another thing that humans for
our design is the hot stuff tab so it's
possible to keep the optimized very code
admitted because the our platform
independent
across multiple startups yeah we should
say a bit first about the small talk
program format so you know most systems
that were talking about here certainly
JavaScript
startup from some clean state so the
that the problem that they they have is
that they start up JavaScript programs
start off with with the text that's
downloaded from the web server it needs
to be compiled and anything you're
starting off from from a simple state
small talk has quite a different
architecture
semental has what's called a snapshot
which is a freezing of its heap so what
what's stored on on the disk is is all
of the objects that make up your small
talk system bitmaps that certainly class
objects and and methods and when you
bring up the system you basically just
floating in this this file image of the
heap into the VM populating that the
heap and and letting it go so and
there's the ability to snapshot the
system at any point so that the
programmer chooses when to when to save
and this natural process just just
freezes the whole heap so what what
we've we've got in our system is because
we construct these optimized methods as
normal bytecode methods and they live in
the method dictionaries in classes we
could save the system in a lot to my
state so we're doing something that the
traditional JIT vm's just can't do yeah
we needed to say level 3 so another
thing we try to build is like different
tools to be able to easily debug to
optimize out because it's in small talk
so to use the small type debugger all
the small tokens vectors but we tried to
do more than that so we try to build a
tool to very date between each 15
accession paths that the internet
representation is in a clean state and
that allows us to find out with many
bugs and to guarantee that if someone
wants to contribute to an optimization
pass out or something it could not crush
the root system so what we want to do in
the future is to also target Dobrev
metrics so right now in small talk we
use a box a presentation of
double-precision floating-point oh it's
that is true so most developers avoid to
use 13 1000 smooth-talked simply and we
want to give our two controller when the
your turn when the graph generation
needs two books on unbox the
floating-point object to avoid the extra
conditions and to speed up the
computation yeah go back go back
so the way that we we do that if you
look at a Java Virtual Machine in Java
bytecode
Java has in it the notion of some of the
byte codes accessing the the object
representation in a method and some of
the byte codes specifying unboxed
floating point operations so the
abstract model of a Java stack is some
part of it is object pointers and some
part of it is flat data and some of the
byte codes access that flat byte data
performing floating point operations or
other unbox operations and some of the
byte codes access the object part of the
stack doing things like virtual calls
etc etc so if we enrich our model of the
activation record so that we have a byte
array in it that can hold the flat data
we can add unsafe byte code operations
that do floating-point operations on
that that byte array so we have an
abstract model of how its executed and
indeed in the interpreter part you know
if we were in in in small talk in the
debugger stepping through those byte
codes though that that is actually what
would happen but our optimization our
optimizing compiler that the baseline
JIT has that has the job of mapping that
byte array down onto the floating-point
registers and converting those byte
codes that that address the byte array
into instructions on the floating point
register state and so that's an
interesting example of how in our
layered architecture as as was mentioned
in the introduction we have this
separation of concerns where the base
level jet has the the job of mapping
machine registers to to stack slots and
then the higher level of the system has
the job of mapping the stack slots back
to the the abstract execution state and
and this dynamic deoptimization process
which is quite complicated poses a
problems in in systems that are not so
layered and is mentioned in the in the
in the literature as as a problem area
and in our double layer system the the
computation is is simpler because it's
been split in two into two levels so
that's that that's it and to say a
little bit more about that the project
level is a PhD student at INRIA French
lab in in Lille in northern France I've
been a small talk implementer for a long
time and employed at cadence and and
semi independent and the virtual machine
that we have which is called corgis is
open-source there's a website where you
can find out about it if you're
interested in finding out more about the
system or even using it for projects or
collaborating please get in touch with
us in email or the virtual machine
development list that's at the bottom in
the in the squeak community is used to
discuss the virtual machine which is
used in a number of systems small talk
dialects like Faro squeak and and crease
but also the the Newspeak modular small
talk system designed by Gilad bracha of
the java specification fame so we hope
we can interest some of you into coming
in and getting further involved because
we offer a context in which the
development of an optimizing compiler is
something done in a very high-level
language something we didn't have time
to touch on here is that indeed the base
level jet the lower parts of the system
is also a small talk program and that's
developed interactively as a simulator
and it's something that is converted to
see and then compiled to form our
production vm but during development
as well as we're developing that that
jet including you know the
implementation of those unsafe byte
codes and and the things like that the
the floating-point arithmetic stuff that
we that we hope to do soon that's again
implemented in a high-level language and
and has an interactive development
experience even though it punches out a
fixed VM well we've got one minute left
we touched on this repeatedly from sort
of the Java via the Java approach and
the small talk approach arm and this is
bad war sort of not a war but a
distinction in the idea of thirty eight
schism there was a list machine view of
the world where there was a sea bird
view in the world and JavaScript is sort
of on the seaside Java a drop well the
JavaScript - because it's sort of you
you don't ever save anything and a few
little snapshot that went well programs
don't get faster there's as fast as
they'll ever be
yes which was actually the argument for
around four stations is that they're
always as fast as they're going to be
they don't get faster if I think they
were never fast enough until it work
this social stuff is that playing in any
interesting way or that the Java people
reduced in JavaScript people
rediscovering the world are they oh it's
silly it's certainly true if you if you
if you if you trace them that the
personnel um it's quite interesting
Peter George Peter Deutsche's work
inspired the the self team of Dave Unger
and Hursley and others was contacted by
some people who thought that there was
the prospect of implementing fastest
mobile virtual machines remunerative Lee
for the Wall Street
turns out the small talk is is used in
the financial industry a lot because
domains if all very quickly because of
the legislative environment and
violently types untyped languages of one
of the few languages where the
government can keep up with with the
rate of development of the real world so
they thought that there was the the the
the potential of making a big profit if
they could implement apply this
technology to small talk and and and
that was joined up with a very very able
program Accord laws back to do what was
called strong talk the stroke would be
and there was a bidding war because
producing strong they could see that
Java had just arrived this is now
mid-90s and they decided to do a Java VM
at the same time that they did a small
tot VM and indeed it was a son that
bought java they had deeper pockets than
that the smaller community and so that
technology which started off small talk
and self realized itself in in Java
first from from Sun and then later on
Lars went to Google to speed up
JavaScript because JavaScript was so
important and his VM the first VM is
called v8 and internally that VM
recreates a lot of Smalltalk runtime
properties to allow it to apply these
techniques so in the JavaScript model we
only have double precision numbers and
and and and notionally we would either
box or we would do that fantastic trick
from old Lisp machines where objects are
not our numbers and so everything's a
number and you just use the small part
of the address space with the 53 bits of
mantissa and you're and you're not a
number indicator to actually address
objects and so that's when way of doing
or the other way of doing it which is in
v8 is where you do indeed have box
doubles but if the system as it's
compiling text or producing results
finds out that the result is actually
representable as an integer it will use
a tag pointer just like in small talk so
internally doubles are used infrequently
and integers tagged integers are used as
much as possible
and maps are created that correspond to
classes maps define the layout of a
particular object as a sequence of slots
that only has a subset of all of the
properties that it might have etcetera
and so all that machinery came from
small talk and have been reproduced
internally inside the VM so these these
VMs are quite quite recognizable so in
in there's that hidden way in which the
technology has been been recovered but
that's that really comes to the the
Schism because what the the community
that's unaware of the vm technology is
proposing is the right way to deal with
this dynamism is to add things like
final where we can declare a class as
something that can't have subclasses and
therefore we know that nothing will be
overridden and therefore we can you know
and the virtual machine community knows
that that that way just doesn't buy you
anything you can do that automatically
you know and and and and so why why
bother so I don't want to say more than
then I think it's very very difficult to
communicate this information to the
broader community it's not it's not
obvious stuff and we haven't necessarily
done a good job even of talking to
language designers because people are
still proposing adding stata fires to
dynamic languages whereas I think that
the the state of the compiling of
compiling for dynamic languages while
it's what it's it's not reached exactly
the same performance is still increasing
well and again catching up to static
compilers and and and still has a lot of
future
this a secret medicine that that a lot
of languages are all alive with there's
lots of money that people just don't
think about I keep finding out about new
ones I I thought I knew all I thought I
knew all the old languages yes else in
fact well yeah just a few days ago we
were visiting lamb research in the East
Bay we have a relationship with them
they are the one of the world's leading
producers of chip manufacturing machines
they build these huge machines which are
full of things like for example one of
the things that these machines might be
full of is a two-step gas so what's a
two-step gas a two-step gas is a gas
which if you inhale it you will walk two
steps before you drop dead that's what
that's what our two-step gases and so
this these machines are very very
interesting there's an incredibly
sophisticated use of surface physics etc
but there's there's some impressive
industrial robotics going on moving
these these wafers from from machine to
machine you might have as many as 200
steps in 200 separate machines in in the
production of a chip as many as 70 days
to produce a chip all of that control
technology is done in small talk it was
a DoD financed NOAA DARPA finance
project in the 90s that produced the
system called control works and it
probably every smartphone on the on the
planet was at some time going through a
machine that was controlled by small
talk so you know these these these
apparently hidden old languages are used
in very very important ways
and we just don't don't hear about the
string devices - yes
we call it in this country we call them
one whiff we get one whiff and then you
keel over
you know they're they're real serious
yeah yeah thank you thank you
you